à l'île de la tentation alors abbas a
dit donc ça encore baissé soit 489 mille
téléspectateurs et seulement 2,1 oui on
la ressent du public a été la salle à ce
faible mais très puissant sur le duel
toujours le public du public alors
l'aspect naguère souvenez vous il y
avait eu il y avait eu un premier joue
entre julien et une tentatrice
il s'était hissé et s'était rapproché et
marées il mari a découvert la vidéo est
là la question fatidique va tomber drame
marie souhaité qu est ce que vous avez
vu
il faudrait être un peu frisquette sur
un an
jésus
[Musique]
là on va
c'est trop
donc je vais encore me détacher du lot
[Applaudissements]
il avait promis un programme sauf bon là
à base de sauvetage commun ils ont tenu
leurs promesses machin dont j'ai juste
une question ont fait l'île de la
tentation on regarde on saisit va se
passer quelque chose au bout de deux
heures et demie if leur tâche est
charles ingalls dans la petite maison
dans la prairie il a pêché tu vois pas
dû arriver à quelque chose rapidement
comme vous les voyez en train de pleurer
alors moi j'ai juste une question où
elles vont dans la ligne de la tentation
est ce qu'elles pensent qu'elles vont
faire pékin express ou une virée les
aventuriers madoff non mais attendez
alors le patron de w9 jérôme fouqueray
avait promis de mettre l'accent sur les
valeurs de la famille et sa dignité
alors je voudrais rappeler à jérôme
fouqueray le principe de la famille
voilà c'est la sincérité peut-être non
c'est pas du tout ce programme qu'il
fallait faire il fallait faire tournez
manège des manèges jouer encore sur la
fidélité encore et encore les amours et
hier et hier et hier ça chauffe ça
chauffe et douce à chauffer de ouf
il ya eu rencontre il ya eu sex and onex
il ya eu couette du matelas il ya eu lie
des literies non mais ça mais vous me
manquer mais il a manqué des dix matches
parce qu'évidemment ils m'ont mis un
plan de la porte et qu'on a regardé
[Rires]
il
c'est râlant d'indépendance
je suis trop fier parce que genre
gmail avec le plus beau de l'âge
il a fait front soir
[Musique]
wario laporte mettez pas la porte
amélie amélie franchement j'adorerais
l'île de la tentation sur tf1 mais
j'étais fan c'était genre mon émission
fétiche et je trouve que les come back
en télé ça marche pas c'est comme le
sexe c'est du réchauffé à n'en pas les
actionnent des outils politiques il ya
des ex mais on est bien on est vachement
death and on n'en sait rien il est
proposé un dîner pas quels buts surtout
mais on est déçu il ya des autos est ce
qu'il ya des retours gagnants ont été
d'ailleurs une nouvelle star c'était pas
un truc c'est vraiment gagnant
excusez-moi j'ai bel air annonce n'est
pas bon non non c'était il ya eu la
famille en or qu'a pas très bien marché
non plus il a fait la fortune cap
atrassi avec christophe dechavanne
énorme succès arrivée sur tf1 mais bien
sûr à cette allure est quand même temps
sa durée ou moins 5 6 ans mais j'étais
juste avant avec la peau qu'on sent bien
sûr que oui moi par contre ça a duré
moins de temps qu passer par deux tours
gagnon l'a en tout cas clément ah ouais
c'est pas et les taux les banques il
aurait dû faire ça à 22h30 aller-retour
exactement il ne se passe rien alors
vous dites et à la couette et ses amis y
a rien été onze ans au bout de l'ennui à
l'émission on ne voit rien au bout de la
nuit surtout si c'était pour nous
montrer ça c'est pas la peine
un truc à l'eau de rose ratté jour qu'à
2 sauf cabane 2h30 sur w9 s'est pas
assez rentable nous a laissé un
programme qui a un fort investissement
il ne fallait pas le faire des économies
au groupe et si on veut voir tout le
monde râle lorsqu'on monte pas tout le
monde râle c'est vrai alors vous voulez
quoi